[Applause]
thank you hannah very much indeed and
i'm going to go completely off script to
start with and say as an islington girl
how wonderful it is to be back in the
union chapel as many of you here is when
i came to see billy bragg
you're very brave to come out on a rainy
monday night we're very pleased that you
haven't lost the habit of coming to live
events we very much look forward to
hearing from our speakers in just a
moment and your participation and of
course we started with a really small
topic can we fix capitalism
uh no point in messing about we went for
the the big topic with intelligence
squared tonight and i thought it was an
interesting moment to step back of
course from all the internal
party political party fighting and to
invite two people with very wide-ranging
views and very wide-ranging experience
of the topic but before they get their
say in the democratic manner we thought
you should have you'll say first or at
least your show of hands a way of
communicating with us
so we're going to ask first who thinks
capitalism albeit with tweaks and
reforms is still the best economic
system we've got
so if you think that give us a wave
this is fabulously oh she's off
julian is just i think i think that's my
job in this whole event
leave your hand up just a minute can i
have a look can is everyone
unscientifically taking stop i like the
way that julian voted for herself there
it's a good moment and who thinks we
need a completely new economic system
thank god because otherwise it was the
wrong booking
but that was fairly clearly
capitalism can be fixed in our audience
tonight but i would say from intelligent
square debates i've done a few recently
obviously far less interesting in the
sense of being uh online only there was
quite a lot of shifting around once that
people had heard the speakers so the
that is really where we're going to go
next i would perhaps give them this
challenge from the marxist literary
critic frederick jameson who once said
it's easier to imagine the end of the
world than the end of capitalism i
wonder whether that is still the case
i'm going to uh turn first i think
janice is going to to lead us off
tonight if i read my annals true janice
varoufakis will be known to many of you
from our screens and his fiery
contributions to this debate
he was greek finance minister from
january to july
2015 a short period but one in which he
managed to be in the headlines in those
days
he resigned refusing to sign a loan
agreement on the grounds it would worsen
greece's economic circumstances which
brought him into some conflict with
angela merkel who's just uh leaving the
international stage as german chancellor
at the moment
nowadays he is chair of political
economy at the university of athens as
well as visiting professor of political
economy at king's college london a
best-selling author of many books
including another now dispatches from an
alternative present
bit of a clue there i think and a
wonderful one actually which i remember
talking to him about a few years ago
called talking to my daughter about the
economy a brief history of capitalism i
once interviewed janice and said you're
a bit of a champagne socialist aren't
you he said no no not really but so i
don't like champagne but i like very
good white wine
i hope that's still the case janice
murpakis the floor is yours five minutes
on can we fix capitalism
thank you anne it is wonderful to be
back not only the union chapel but also
yeah with people in the same
space
okay now the problem with these um boys
games you know oxford union debates is
that uh the force upon us
a dichotomy you know either either
you're in favor of emotion or against
emotion which is fun
but not very helpful
so allow me to answer the question in my
own way
i don't think it's
an interesting question
whether we should fix capitalism
because
capitalism and this is something that i
have
managed to convince myself of in the
last year or so
and with the subject of my next book
i i think that
2021
is
a little bit like
the 1790s
when adam smith was writing the wealth
of nations
in the sense that
the world was feudal
but there were small
pockets of capitalism
that were emerging
that
adam smith managed to cut onto you know
glasgow university it was happening
and just below him in the clyde valley
he could see it but it was tiny it was a
speck of capitalist dust
in
you know a desert of feudalism
still adam smith managed to
see that what was growing you know under
his window in the clydes and in
manchester and elsewhere
uh was infecting feudalism and feudalism
was not going to be on the way out even
when marx was writing the communist
manifesto and
of course you know the first five six
pages are appearing to capitalism really
all about you know breaking down
superstition
and
you know ushering in new technologies
and so on
it was a kind of prequel to
globalization which was not actually
taking place
he was um ahead of his time
i think we are in a similar moment
i think that capitalism is on
his way out
not because the left one
in our pathetic lot
have managed to overthrow no we
have not done that we if anything we
have solidified capitalism i'm talking
about the left
through our
orchestrated idiocy
across many countries and continents no
but capitalism is overthrowing itself in
the same way that feudalism overthrew
itself
and here's some food for thought and for
criticism
by jillian
look
before we can have any meaningful
discussion about capitalism we have to
define our terms what is capitalism
capitalism has transformed itself so
magnificently over the centuries
you know the capitalism of adam smith
doesn't exist it's not the baker
the brewer and the butcher
since the second industrial revolution
it was you know the henry ford's the
edisons the large monopoly or the goblet
capital then we had big government with
the new deal
and the great society then after that we
had financialized capitalism or interior
capitalism you know
it really has this capacity to transform
itself but throughout all these
transformations capitalism retained two
main characteristics
first
the fuel that drives it is profit
profitability profit which then
gets reinvested
becomes new capital and the thing goes
on
the second characteristic of capitalism
is markets
the creation of the labor market
following the enclosures
uh the eviction of the peasants from the
lands created a mass of workers who then
became the proletariat
the commodification of the land
every
process
production process extraction process
is happening through markets
so profits and markets central pillars
of capitalism
looking around
i already see it's at very early stage
wherever we look at we see capitalist
relations there's no doubt about that in
the same way that wherever adam smith
looked around him around the world it's
mostly it was mostly feudal relations
but i think that i can already see
the end of capitalism
because
on the one hand profits have ceased to
be the fuel
of the economic system we have
it is central bank money now
without central bank money the whole
thing collapses even the sectors that
big tech and so on that are highly
profitable
they are squeezing out all the other
sectors and
participating in ending the markets and
replacing them with platforms amazon
facebook and so on they are not
alternative markets they are new
technological systems you enter amazon
you exit the marketplace you exit
capitals you enter a realm where
everything that is being bought and sold
is controlled by one algorithm one
person one owner this is like a fifth
dome only it's a techno techno
victim so for me the question is not can
we fix capitalism
the question is
is it true
is my hunch right
that we are already moving into
a post-capitalist system which i call
techno feudalism for
want of a better term
and given that this techno federalism is
highly
at odds
with liberalism with adam smith
not just with socialists
what do we do how do we
plan
our collective strategy
for not becoming
techno
peasants
within this global technofeudalism
you left us there hanging on a note
where many of us have probably spent the
day feeling like techno peasants one way
or the other as we we struggled with the
bits of technology which they told us
long ago would make our lives easier and
you know
seem to take up about three hours of the
day so that's a really interesting
challenge and particularly i'm going to
hang on to that final point we're going
to hear a bit of to and fro conversation
between our panelists in in just a
moment which i'll moderate but we must
hear from julian tet for the other side
of the coin on fixing capitalism and no
one better to discourse on that julian
is chairman of the us editorial board
and u.s editor in at large at the
financial times she has covered
capitalism i think in how many countries
would you say over your career julian
quite a lot quite a lot she said
mystifyingly but certainly not only
american capitalism but the uk asia you
were based in japan for a while so you
you have a truly global
prism on this she's also co-founder of
the very successful moral money section
of the financial times which is
dedicated to environmental social and
governance i.e esg in the new linga news
that investors and companies are
increasingly embracing her new book is
anthro vision how anthropology can
explain business and life and she's a
former academic anthropologist by
background in her first degree so a very
broad view of capitalism jillian what it
means how it works
and i'm suspecting how you think it
might be fixed well thank you very much
indeed and it's great to be here tonight
i feel at a disadvantage with janice as
my adversary because not only have i
ever tried to run an economy but sitting
here in islington he is on his home turf
home pitch and i'm not
but
i'm going to try and defend capitalism
but not
the current form of capitalism
because i'm trained as an anthropologist
and one of the things anthropologists
spend a lot of time doing is look at the
gap between what people say they do
and what they actually do
between rhetoric between the rituals and
symbols they aspire to and the actual
lived reality
and the core of my argument is
that the capitalist flag the flag of
adam smith that jan has talked about
has been waved around a lot in recent
years by politicians by business leaders
by financiers yes by financial
journalists but what we have today is
not what adam smith sketched out
to understand that you have to go back
and realize that there are two books of
adam smith
and only one has been focused on in
recent years
the wealth of nations lays out a theory
about why competition is good
i happen to believe
to channel i hate to say it boris
johnson by quoting winston churchill
that actually competition and profit is
the worst way to organize an economy
except for all the others that have been
tried
i say that having lived in the former
soviet union where i did my research and
seen other
other visions um playing out
but
when adam smith laid out his two his
vision of capitalism his vision of
market forces he didn't use the word
capitalism his vision of markets he had
two books the wealth of nations about
competition and trade and the theory of
moral sentiments
which is one of the inspirations for the
moral money column which i co-founded at
the financial times
and that vision essentially argued that
there were four components you needed to
make markets effective
you needed to have free access to
markets people had to be able to take
part in them
you need to have free access to prices
people needed to know what the prices
were in a transparent way
you needed to have an illusion of
ownership between the people who managed
ventures and actually owned them which
in adam smith day were mostly family
owned owned firms so it wasn't a problem
and you needed to have a shared moral
ethical and legal base which basically
provided a foundation for people to have
shared values and shared trust
remember the roots of the word credit
come from the latin to trust and without
that it's very hard to have a market
now
if you dial back and think about what
was happening two decades ago on wall
street
you can see that all four of those
components were missing
people did not have equal access to the
markets because guess what it was
powerful cartels on wall street and the
city of london who were running the show
they didn't have access to prices
because yes you can get access to stock
market prices but there's many other
prices in finance that are not visible
to the wider public
there wasn't effective collision of
ownership and management because guess
what
the people who were supposedly owning
companies which is all of us for our
pension funds tended to outsource that
to asset managers who were largely
asleep at the wheel and didn't
understand what was happening inside
companies or banks
and there hasn't been a shared moral
framework or even one could argue a
legal and ethical framework essentially
putting what's been happening in
business and finance into the wider
social context anthropologists are
obsessed with context
obsessed with a sense of consequence of
what business and finance does
i would argue that many of those
shortcomings are found in other areas of
modern capitalism
such as the tech sector which janus just
spoke about i'd actually agree with you
that there is a fundamental problem of
monopoly power of a lack of transparency
of a lack of access inside the tech
sector as well and so i would agree with
you that capitalism actually isn't
particularly effective there at the
moment because we don't actually have
that at the moment we have a gap between
rhetoric
and reality
and yet
i personally still think
that
that vision of competition
that vision of using profits to be
reinvested back in growth
that idea that actually
innovation occurs
when you have some friction
when you have a sense of personal
responsibility
that is still a good set of principles
to be using to be driving an economy
forward
so for those reasons i remain a fan of
adam smith when you look at both books
and i'll leave you with two last ideas
which again infuses how i see capitalism
how i'd like to see capitalism play out
as an anthropologist again i'm
fascinated by words and language
i don't know how many of you know here
where the word company comes from
originally
i talk about it in my book
it originally comes from latin
from old old italian actually con paneo
meaning with
bread because companies were originally
seen as groups of people who ate
together and then did business together
similarly i don't know how many of you
know where the word finance comes from
but it actually comes from old french
veneer meaning to finish
which sounds completely bizarre because
people think that finance is basically
never ending loops of money going round
and round like sugar in a candy floss
maker building a bigger bigger puff of
speculation that's kind of meaningless
but originally finance was about paying
off blood debts and finishing
actual tangible commercial transactions
it was a means to an end not an end in
itself
so to go back to adam smith if you put
those two books together the vision of
capitalism that i uphold is one where
companies are recognized to be about
humans and groups of people competing
together building things together and
money is a means to an end the fuel that
drives forward the economy and growth
and i personally think that is a vision
that we should be upholding and aspiring
to today
and i'll say last of all i realized
janus and i both got the dark blue shirt
memo so we may end up agreeing more than
we're disagreeing and sadly
effortlessly stylish
i thought i'd just um just pick up a
couple of points there to to question
both of you janice she's just trying to
put together a list in my head and it's
a pretty obvious one but it goes
something like this karl marx
vladimir ilyich lenin
stalin boo
any number of post-war communist leaders
and supporters after the great rift in
in europe of course in in 1939-45
1968 radicalism maoism
and
on home turf jeremy corbyn
um
sort of in illustrious company um
you see that the
line of argument there's and each of
them has seen the death rows of
capitalism in some form
and yet here we all are having a
discussion about whether we can fix it
what makes you think
that this time it's different factor
applies to 2021
you're quite right uh
every socialist and
account myself as one
um has always been like a stopped clock
that eventually tells the
the right time
you know we kept
predicting a massive financial collapse
ever since i was you know 10
and it happened in 2008 so eventually
you know
all our predictions come true
it doesn't mean we will write
analytically about it
look
why do i think that
this time
it's different
to quote famous economists
first
i'll repeat some of the things i said
but
in a different manner hopefully
helpfully
take what happened in the summer of 2020
here in london i think it was the 12th
of august
when you had the
announcement
that
your gdp fell by more than 20
for the first time in the history of
british capitalism remember that
august 2020
the market expectations were for a
fall of about 12 13
it was much much more than that
and yet 15 16 minutes later the london
stock exchange went up
that has never happened before in the
history of capitalism
why did it happen for a very logical
reason
because market players thought oh my god
20 plus then this immediately
nanoseconds later they thought
okay if we're panicking the bank of
england are panicking so they're going
to print loads of money
and they will pump it in our direction
okay
to refloat the disaster
so let's keep buying
okay now
this is simply a little tale that i tell
in order to capture the manner in which
financial markets have completely
decoupled from really existing
capitalism and if you think about it in
2008 we had in 1929 our generations 1929
the difference with 1929 was that unlike
the hoover administration in the united
states in 29 that let the banks fall
uh the
g7 g20 april 2009 gordon brown london
decided to float them
so they went
into
a spasm of
printing mountain ranges of money to
refloat the financial markets which they
did very successfully
proof that if they want to do something
they do they do it right
but ever since they did that
and they did it in a staggered way the
european central bank really began doing
it in 2012 and then went all out in 2015
with mario draghi first of march
but
the way i see it now capitalism has
completely been hooked
on the central bank money
and
therefore why is jeff bezos
50 billion dollars richer than he was at
the beginning of the pandemic it's not
the profits of amazon of his businesses
it is the increase in the share market
because what happens is qe means that uh
you know the central bank prints money
they
give it they effectively given a higher
a larger overdraft
to you know the
bagless banks deutsche banks of the
world
they look at you people to say oh no
we're not going to lend them because
they're hopeless so they pick up the
phone they call volkswagen siemens asks
them
you know google apple and they say do
you want a few billion those people
don't need money because they already
have stashes of money which itself is a
problem because corporations should be
borrowing not not saving but they take
their money because it's free
and they take it and they go to the
stock exchange and they buy back their
own shares
okay so now you have a bifurcation of
of capitalism you have the companies
that maintain profitability because
it's not monopoly that they have
for me amazon you know um
general motors had a monopoly or an
oligopoly
amazon is different it's a platform it
means that you exit capitalism you exit
the market and you go into a place that
where everything that is sold or bought
are controlled by one company one
algorithm that is very difficult because
there's quite a lot in there janice let
jillian come back
on that qe quantitative easing money
slashing just one one final phrase then
i can throw it over to you yeah one
final phrase
so
if
[Music]
if what i'm saying holds water
then adam smith is simply not relevant
he's as relevant as karl marx was in the
soviet union when you were there in
other words not at all
so you're saying adam is not relevant
because the financial markets today
don't tie into the real economy and
because essentially you have platform
monopolies on technology
yes and even the companies that are not
platform companies through private
equity takeovers they're being taken
over loaded by with debt which is
financialized
those companies are then
split up asset stripped
so you have the squeezing of the capital
sector
of what adam smith would consider to be
the capitalist sector you know the
squeezing of it completely until
all you have is central banks on the one
hand
financial markets
and
the platforms so let me turn around and
say like this would you believe that
competition is a good thing in an
economy absolutely
okay let me ask for questions do you
believe
that prices are useful
yes yes i've read my highest okay i
understand do you believe that profits
are a good thing as an incentive and
that you should reinvest profit back
into ventures
no
but i do believe that no hang on
wait wait because of you know after
when you read this you'll see um
there's a chapter in there called
markets with without capitalism
right so i in it i tried to answer your
question by
in this book i tried to create a
blueprint of
how we could have done things
differently this is the book
so in in my in my utopia
in my in this utopia in the other now
that i call it uh markets are essential
because
iris the anthropologist modeled after
you right as you know
uh she says that you know at some point
that
the only thing that stops
uh authoritarianism and the soviet kind
of gulag from descending upon us is
markets and competition and freedom
freedom of enterprise
but the problem is that
the the moment you have
share markets
that are being effectively
turbocharged
through central bank money
and you have the financialization that
you experience and you explain very
nicely in the book then
the
competition dies so your basic argument
is with equity markets and the current
form of equity markets and
stockholding companies if i understand
it rightly i mean let me say this if you
believe that competition is valuable
if you believe that prices matter
if you believe in a diversification of
different roles and specialist functions
and that's good i believe in all that
okay well that doesn't make you sound
very socialist with orbit or due respect
well
that is not true
do you remember oscar lange
sorry oscar lange right do you remember
oscar yeah you may need to remind us
1920s
one of friedrich von hagek's great
adversaries the other was
john manier keynes oscar lanky was a
socialist communist actually
who believed in
not the center he was completely against
the idea of of a central plan
but he was in favor of what effectively
i have tried to
you know to map out in this book
[Music]
a market
where let me give you an example right
imagine a world where
you join a corporation
and you get one share in the same way
that you enroll in university you get a
library card
and that library card that one share
gives you one vote it allows you to do
stuff you know borrow books participate
in decision making and so on and then
when you have to leave when you leave
you take your capital out and you have
to hand over your library card your one
share
now
just for a moment
go along with this imagine you have a
market
where you have competition between
companies
that are owned
by those who happen to work in them
and you have you
you ask me whether i don't believe in
profits no i don't because if you have
that system
you have net revenues because there's no
distinction between profits and wages
everybody profit shares and then you're
going to chip in and ask you did say you
believed in competition absolutely
diversity so i wanted them what you're
going to do with your prophets
julian asked you that then you said and
she said that's not socialist and you
said well actually it is but then i was
got a bit confused sorry this is
of course but what would you do with the
profits oh you reinvest them
or you divide them so let's turn them
out let me give you an example and this
is this is this is a
really existing example i won't mention
the company but i've worked for that
company back in 2011 2012. it's in
washington state united states so
imagine look it up
look it up
imagine a company where
the revenue
total revenue is divided in four parts
one part
is
fixed costs
rents and servers and stuff the second
part is r d
the third part is the basic income of
everybody working from you know the
janitor all the way to
the arch designer
and the fourth part is bonuses
and imagine that
the rnd
segment
is
decided as a result of a vote
where
the members employees vote between
different business plans that are
presented once a year once every two
years
the basic pay the same and then bonuses
are decided on the basis of the
eurovision song contest scoring system
where every employee gets 100 points
but you can only
distribute them award them to other
people depending on
your understanding your appreciation of
their estimation so the problem is with
yourself is actually quite good except
britain would always lose
you know this is a different
corporate structure right
the company wants to maximize its
revenues
there's no there is competition
but there's no capitalism it doesn't and
there's no distinction between wages and
profits okay the idea that workers get
skin in the game yes absolutely the idea
they have some checks and balances and
some involvement absolutely the idea
you're going to organize
50 500 people into a committee to take
through business decisions
have you ever tried organizing 10 people
into taking swift decisions well you
know i'm greek so i can't organize
myself i have five opinions
therein lies my point because i think i
think you have a slightly higher
vision of what humans will do to left
their own devices but it doesn't have to
be a committee it doesn't have to be
committed firstly in the company
can you name one cooperative
that has actually swelled in size and
become a really effective
operation okay let me tell you that the
company i'm referring to had 350
employees and 1.2 billion dollars of
revenue a year
and it worked really very well with
complete flat management so why aren't
there more companies copying that
because
they're being gobbled up this is why
because you know think of
the the trustee savings bank remember
what happened to it it was gobbled up so
the idea of cooperatives that work is
well established from the 19th century
in this country yeah cooperative banks
cooperative
supermarkets and so on that work
magnificently but in an environment in
an economic environment where you know
the the the large fish it's a smaller
fish especially you know the smaller um
energetic fish
what's happening in in silicon valley
all the time but the issue you know
google and so on they're destroying
competition by buying them up
so
you know that company in particular
right you have no no idea i mean i'm
sure you do uh the extent to which there
were all these attempts by big money to
buy it out
and and it will it will go but that's a
separate issue that's a separate issue
because you're basically arguing two
things on the one hand you have the
question of what's the best way to
organize a bunch of people who want to
be in business and get money to fund
that should they sit around as a happy
cooperative and sing kumbaya doesn't
have to be happy it's not going to be
happening
i'm
but that's one question i.e how do they
get money to finance what they're doing
um and the second question then is is
there a regulatory structure to create a
level playing field that stops the
winners from essentially taking all and
buying up the other two separate
questions this is great and i would
agree on the second point that
absolutely we need better umpires to
create regulatory structures that stop
winners taking all and doing unfair
competition comes back to my four points
about adam smith on the question of how
to organize companies um yes
cooperatives can sometimes work yes i
happen to think that with digital
technology probably is getting easier to
organize that than before and digital
transparency is changing things
radically and i think in many ways maybe
the savior of capitalism and i can talk
about that if you want however
i happen to think that in most cases the
ability to raise outside money
from people who have a stake in the
company which is called an equity market
is a pretty efficient way of doing it
unless and i would agree with you unless
you have
central banks printing all the cash
which essentially is distorting prices
right now i don't like what the central
banks have done in recent years yeah but
you know what jillian it can't be
otherwise we are in this situation where
now if central banks stop printing money
the whole thing collapses so you're
saying you don't like capitalism 2021
version but like what i'm saying is that
that that you are being completely topic
in you i think you talked absolutely
you're being your topic well
[Laughter]
let's speak your topic in
[Laughter]
is more realistic than yours the idea of
going back to a capitalism that works is
absolutely impossible now and you
mentioned you said you talked about the
importance of having empires of improper
regulation it's impossible
they will always be captured because the
concentration of power
now under this what i call
technocriticalism is always going to be
so gigantic that there is no government
on this planet however well meaning its
functionaries that can do it this is why
i'm saying that if you really want
competition
and freedom and liberalism to be given a
chance we need to move away from share
markets we need to go to a system where
you ask the question where where does
the capital come coming from from
savings
we need to do that which
adam smith recognized because adam smith
was exactly on my side here he was
totally against public limited companies
because he understood that the moment
you have liquid ownership you have the
ownership split up in tiny little pieces
that can be traded anonymously in the
stock exchange suddenly
his prerequisites for a well-functioning
competitive market are gone
so why not just have pension funds
automatic enrollment to have people
owning asset you know mutual funds and
things like that providing some of the
fuel for investing in companies and then
combine that with radical digital
transparency
so that people can actually track what
companies are doing and actually express
an idea of vote if they want to
i'm going to move on because the pension
funds are taking over
the pension funds will always be taken
over by those who happen to have
a greater um
percentage so why not ownership than
others they will all i mean look look at
you know the three big you know
state street vanguard and so on the
control yeah 90 of the new york stock
exchange
so you know who controls them
so why not work on reforming the pension
funds and getting better financial
oversight and regulation and working
with a system that appears to
actually in many ways spark innovation
and growth it can be done better but why
not work with that rather than aspire
for something which has never actually
materialized anywhere in the world on
any scale effectively australian capital
is never materialized anywhere in the
world until it did
save it for the q a you're going to be
first
it's always good to know there's someone
in the audience and in any case i'm
arguing that
is already evolving
a bit i want to move us on because i
think we're in danger perhaps on the
markets and models i did a little bit of
a squeeze on julian on on one point that
i've heard and this is the problem the
big tech monopolies and what that means
and we need to remind ourselves the
unprecedented levels of growth and
consolidation yeah so what are you going
to do about yeah well it's about
facebook because what i'm saying is you
know corporate law which says one
employee one share that kills off the
power of facebook what is your proposal
okay
hang on
it's more awkward
right gosh it's through that
you are behaving beautifully um
just in your way no
what i was thinking about what you said
about the regulator which was an
interesting thought but look there's an
example julian how many people eminent
people in
america and elsewhere run round in
circles saying we need better regulation
than tech companies mark zuckerberg
doesn't give a anyway it just doesn't
happen this and the to this point i
think janus is right to be pushing on
this yeah it would appear to be an area
which is immune to the sort of reformist
regulatory okay let me give my answer to
facebook what i do about facebook and
it's different from what you expect
there's one thing that adam smith got
totally wrong in fact several things but
here's the most important thing for
today
he thought that barter was an
old-fashioned prehistoric practice that
really just involved cavemen sitting
around in caves swapping piles of
berries for meat and he presumed that
barter would essentially die out once
you invented money and credit
he was a hundred percent wrong
economists automatically assume that
barter is old-fashioned and doesn't
matter anthropologists and i don't know
if there are any anthropologists here
tonight
this is your moment anthropologists know
that barter is actually something which
has often been around in many
communities at the same time as
money and credit anyone who's read david
graber's wonderful book debt the first 5
000 years will know this but also it's
gonna help us with the tech i'm gonna
tell you sparta is alive and well today
big time because silicon valley actually
runs off barter the wholesale swap of
data for services
that is the bedrock of much of the tech
sector today it does not involve money
and we have no way of talking about it
day to day except to say that it's free
and we tend to only focus on one aspect
of this which is how tech companies take
our data we don't look at the services
the reason i say this is important
because actually we're missing a lot of
things that are happening in the economy
today and also in terms of corporate
valuations we're also missing something
that i would expect if i was to go to
all of you in the room today and say
would you like to pay for your services
that you get from google facebook your
email would you like to use money to buy
all that
and in exchange they can't take your
data or they'll pay you for it
you might say well yes for privacy
reasons
but i guess that many of you would
actually say you know what i don't want
the hassle of having to use money to pay
for it i like getting free services
so the reason i mentioned all this is
really important
if you want to reform tech today and
create a more ethical tech system
you don't necessarily need to abolish
barter
you need to change the terms of trade of
barter
and that means essentially giving
consumers more power in that bar to
trade which involves one more
transparency about how data is being
used more transparency about what the
companies are doing inside
the company with your data and most
crucially and this comes back to the
power of market forces
data portability
if we had the ability to pull our data
out of any tech company and go somewhere
else
we'd actually have the beginnings of a
proper market
for our service for our us as customers
if you put the on tech companies to
guarantee data portability
then you'd get the beginnings of a
proper market and i'll say two more
things quickly i think that competition
would be more effective in giving
consumers power
and actually saying you know what i hate
what facebook has done so i'm going to
pull my data away and go somewhere else
then it would actually be in terms of
regulation and there is a model for it
already and it's called finance
if you change your bank account today
the onus is on the bank to ensure that
your money goes from one bank to another
it's not on you you don't have to go and
basically physically you know get your
pile of cash out and put it to another
bank that company is required to move
the move your money
that is what we should have for tech
companies today
along with better oversight along with
looking at breaking up platform control
and monopolies in terms of vertical
platforms but actually that is why
consumer power and competition matters
convinced
yes and no let me start with another
okay i take that as a b-plus well you
know that's what you get with when you
have an economist on the one hand on the
other hand remember what truman said i
want a one-handed economist
i'm convinced that we need to change
property rights over data
over personal data so here we are on and
actually in in in my topic um
other now you'll find that there is a
system called and if you haven't seen it
i'm going to show that
you know i describe
various systems one is you know how
banking would work in my socialist
market system
and also how data should work and i have
a system where i
came up with
the label pending for your thoughts so
you know tiny micropayments that are
automatically made by
people so that they can also own their
own data so we're on on the same page on
this but what you're suggesting is not
going it's not doing anything about the
power of facebook anything about the
power of amazon because let's face it
the reason why people are in facebook is
because everybody else is in facebook so
it's economies of scaling the condoms of
scope and there is nothing you can do
about that uh by changing the you know
the system
and one more thing teenagers aren't on
facebook do you have kids teenagers
wouldn't be seen dead on facebook
fashions change surprisingly fast
okay whatever i mean the people who are
on tick tock
be on tick tock because the people they
follow are on tick tock so this these
are the network economies which you
understand very well and when it comes
to amazon
there is this
technological structure that supports a
whole economy that is a non-market and
based on power and there's nothing you
can do about that if you stick to the
idea of liquid property that is owned
and traded in share markets i want to
bring us to something else and of course
feel free to come back to this so we
just need to sort of move through a
couple more cycles of themes perhaps
before we get to questions it would be
very remiss i think on the road to cop26
not to talk about
parole planet earth and the impact of
capitalism on
planet earth and whether you think
julian
that green growth is possible i know
you're a big if you can be a big cheese
can you be a big cheese in esg a big
environmentally friendly produced cheese
in this area suggest that you do believe
in green growth but there are many
reasons are there not if we look around
the planet today and uh man made global
warming to say that capitalism has
played a very negative role in that and
to be rather skeptical
yep i'd come back to the fourth part of
the adam smith framework i laid out
about the need to have a shared ethical
moral legal vision and above all else a
theme that i go on about in my book
which is the need to move from tunnel
vision to lateral vision
most of the tools that we developed in
the late 20th century um to make sense
of the world like economic models
apologies honest because i know you're
an economist but these lovely economic
models these lovely corporate balance
sheets these lovely big data sets are
all very bounded and marked by tunnel
vision you don't need to apologize
because i agree with you
i was trying to needle you but um but
they basically treat everything that
isn't inside the economic model or the
balance sheet as an externality or a
footprint something outside that model
and what i would argue is that one of
the things that went very badly wrong
with a lot of the corporate vision and
the
economic models was
treating the environment
as an externality they ignored who was
going to pay for the damage that was
created or the cost of the natural
resources they were that's quite a big
flaw in the capitalist argument well if
you could actually start measuring that
and putting that into your models you
start to get a very different vision of
how companies are valued how they're
looking at the world there are ways of
doing that and people are developing
that impact weighted accounting
impact weighted accounting esg
accounting is going to thrill the ns
impact rated accounting well for that
you need the
the regulation that you are never going
to be able to have as long as power is
so heavily concentrated
um
let me give you an example because um i
think
we didn't manage to meet and this hammer
because uh half of greece because
everything you just turned me down no
because half of grace burned down and i
was going from
by the way you know that exactly is what
happened actually in fairness just to
not be trying to and you missed you
missed you missed an important part of
my cv in these days you know i lead the
political party in greece
you presented me as if i'm an author and
professor i did that that's a previous
life
so
you aspire to have power yeah but the
reason why i mentioned the the the the
fires is because look
speaking of green growth okay
um
i also believe that in in green growth
but i also believe in green big growth
there are things that need to grow and
things that need to grow like we need
less cement less co2 less of all the
toxic derivatives the toxic fumes right
we need fewer of those fewer cars
whether they're electric or not more
public transport
[Music]
but
going back to the forest fires in greece
this summer
this is a failed state right but
nevertheless when it comes to profit
making it's very fast so
the day after
we were devastated and the flames died
down
large corporations came
and took over the
attempt to prevent those uh
forests from uh becoming mud baths with
the first rains
so you think oh that's a good thing they
came to to help
shore up the you know the soil and all
that
first thing they did was to
offer contracts to the local population
that effectively signed all their rights
away
for 20 euros a day okay forget that
that's
you could expect that the second thing
they did
was they're trying to win
um new contracts
for replanting the forests
using genetically modified trees
that will grow very quickly
and they will give them the opportunity
to in in the context of the green
transition
harvest biomass for the purposes of
you know green energy
if we allow them to do this
you're going to have under the
cover of green growth you're going to
have the devastation of the flora and
the fauna of the land
and
the conversion of these areas in heavy
and so on into fifth domes of monsanto
bayer who will have genetically poisoned
the land while making it very green now
is this the green growth that we want
this is the green growth that this
market-based system not because it's a
market but because monsanto is not a
market
toxic monolith
let me come back to this point again
[Applause]
as i said you are on your home pitch
there
there
are
numerous examples of green washing
there's numerous examples of companies
and finances using the green label to do
all kinds of egregious things that i
would completely agree with however
one of the other reasons i believe in
competition is that i believe in checks
and balances
and i don't think we can sit there and
trust government alone to turn us green
when back in the 1970s when milton
friedman developed his vision of
shareholder capitalism which i did not
agree with there were two things that
were very different one back then people
thought that they could outsource the
really difficult decisions in life the
social stuff to governments and
companies just worried about their
balance sheets
and secondly you did not have radical
transparency and most people did not
know what was actually happening inside
companies
today
we have a world where no one actually
trusts the government to get stuff done
and
we have a world where all of you have
cell phones with extraordinary levels of
access to information if you choose
and many aspects of corporate life are
subject to radical transparency the
reason that you know so quickly about
what was happening in those forests
is precisely because of this radical
transparency
so i come back to the point
it's not either all we don't need
government or companies to be green or
ngos
we actually benefit by having different
groups in society doing this it is a
good thing
that actually we're not just relying on
the greek government alone to deal with
replanting those forests it's good that
we have citizens armed with cell phones
giving you the data you just quoted and
it's good that we've had companies
coming in and feeling the need to do
something about it even if they are
being essentially up driven by less than
virtuous principles and even if some of
the things they're doing are wrong
many of the things that companies are
doing today are better than they were
doing two or three decades ago
so my question to you not giannis is
this would you wind back the clock and
have companies to go back to where they
were 20 or 30 years ago would you only
rely on government
the governments we have to shine us
green because look back what's happened
in the last decade it ain't been so good
one of the reasons why companies where
governments are under pressure to come
to cop 26 and do something is partly
because there is a shift in zeitgeist
amongst investors and businesses that
reflect social shifts that comes back to
radical transparency come back on that
because we then must open up to a very
patient audience you're quite clearly
mistaking me for for one of those
socialists that likes the state i loaded
the state
in the same way that i load monsanto and
bayer right
so
my my worry julian is that the state and
those large corporations are in cahoots
they're working together
and
you know for
you know i want diversity i want people
who live in these areas to be empowered
to do things without either buyer
monsanto
you know descending upon them and
effectively taking them over or the
state saying oh i will fix everything
for you the question is how do you
empower communities
with their necessary capital the
necessary expertise
and leave them to their own devices in
order to do stuff
i think that that is the future the
future is for
neither for living
neither under the thumb of the state nor
under the thumb of corporate capital
those companies that go in there are not
going there to do anything good because
of transparency by the way the
transparency
is
an illusion
because you know i'm telling you now
what most of those people know
in those areas of the forests but i can
tell you that not one television station
not one radio station not one newspaper
has ever reported on what is really
happening on the ground
they are owned by the same corporate
interests newsflash not everyone gets
their news anymore from newspapers much
like i'd love them to do it
i'm afraid they do not even not
newspapers but they do get it from
even from the internet sites that have
the capacity to dominate the internet
absolutely right you reminded me that
you lead a a party a newish party in
greece now called
because we have the dm-25 movement in
europe and in greek it's merit i'm going
to ask you just very briefly and i do
want to go to questions we started a bit
late we can only
people here have got very busy social
lives we'll have to let them go at some
point um
what about the wider world you know what
about developing
china at the top scale of kind of
importance in terms of of its uh
economic output india and everything
that flows from that it can be a bit
comfortable perhaps for western
progressives to sit in gatherings like
this saying what they think should
happen on green growth do you think you
could persuade people in countries who
feel that they've come later to the
fruits of capitalism perhaps in china
yes you can call it state capitalism but
it feels quite capitalist when you're in
it that they need to replace their
economic model i have no doubt that the
large majority of people in india in
bangladesh in nigeria
in south africa in china itself
do not want to play catch catch-up with
the west in the sense of more cement
more environmental destruction more
destruction of their communities more
blocks of flats you know destroying
their villages i'm sure that they would
like to be empowered
the difficulty that we have with people
in indian bangladesh is the same
difficult we have here in the united
kingdom in greece in france and germany
and it is because you mentioned david
graber
the difficulty is to move away from
thatcher's dogma of tina that there is
no alternative to what david was saying
that everything could be different
great fantastic what a great point at
which to go to questions you can ask all
the things we didn't get to this is the
bit that gets like strictly come dancing
for me because we've got an audience
here we've got an audience at home and
as one of our producers pointed out
tonight whatsapp isn't working because
mark zuckerberg was having an off day
so this bit is going to be really good
fun please bear with me so if you're in
the audience you'd like to ask a
question well it's the good
old-fashioned way and we are in a a
chapel uq up to the microphone stands
which are at either side of the hall can
someone sort of just give a wave to
where they are if you could right thank
you
what they said
either side so you actually do have to
come to the microphone we're not passing
microphones around at the moment for
obvious reasons
if you are watching online you can ask
questions by putting them into the chat
tab on the right hand side of your
screen
um what's this q and a button under the
video
hang on you're gonna you're gonna miss
the really good bit
um the exciting bit is you can ask a
question by clicking on the q a button
under the video screen and press
send yeah we're obviously we're
obviously doing this uh and people have
never used a computer before press send
people and somehow it's going to show up
with me
who knows how because i don't like the
sound of this very much i'm going to
start with people in the hall but if you
are at home of course you are very much
part of this live event so we will find
a way to turn to your questions
too uh and it's i'm also supposed to
tell you to tweet as well hashtag iq2
so now i've done it please tweet because
otherwise they keep reminding me and
it's just terrible
right
who is it we have people a microphone
well go for it if you're first in the
queue hello
[Music]
yeah sure so
my question is sort of a a spin on one
of the the prompt of this uh discussion
which is just to ask
is capitalism even possible or has it
even been possible as a system of
economic organization
uh because it seems as though the brief
history of capitalism has been
guided by technological advancement
which in turn uh
caused inequality which itself was a
source necessary to finance uh that
growth of capital
and my question is just when you look at
the rise of wealth inequality and the
gap between creditors and debtors that
emerges from that
um and then when you look at economic
recessions and the necessary
uh need for uh uh just like you just
come to the question if you would mind i
think i got the inequality no i don't
mean to be rude i'm so sorry yeah it's
just this kind of everyone's just
pleased to be able to see we've got a
lot of questions in short it seems as
though you need government consistently
in order to sustain capitalism that's
after that thought panel i'm going to
take a question from the other side as
well
hi uh my question is just focusing on
information because i think we said you
know back in the day there was no
asymmetry of information and today
we have all the information that we need
to make informed decisions and for
markets to run efficiently
i would argue that actually
there's do not think that
to fix capitalism we need less asymmetry
of information in the market
i think that today there's more
information but it's not the right
information and without the right
information how are you supposed to fix
these issues well you answer first
janice and we'll flip over to julian
just try to unite the two questions or
take the one that most speaks to your
views or fully formed prejudices
my reaction to your question is
you reminded me of
this great
illusion that
is motivated
that you know capitalism is a system
where
wealth is produced individually and then
the state comes and socializes it when
it's exactly the opposite
and the state has always been part of
the evolution of capitalism regarding
information yes i mean information is
power and
exorbitant power
is
goes hand in hand with the exorbitant
asymmetry in information
uh but it's you know this power comes
it's not simply based on information if
i have a gun and you don't have a gun
you know i have power over you if you're
starving if your kids
are going to bed hungry at night and the
only way of getting you know some milk
or bread
is uh
you know to do whatever i ask you to do
then that's not the question of the
symmetry of information
asymmetry information then comes on top
of it and it gives me even more of an
extravagant exorbitant privilege over
you
um i would argue that if innovation is
power then some elements of the power
structures are changing today
because in the past information really
was held very tightly by vertical
hierarchies and trickled down or at
least as they wanted today
information is available to many many
people and they may not have the ability
to frame it and pass it it's still
concentrated i wouldn't pretend we have
a complete the
democratic information system at all but
there's more information out there today
than there ever was in the past
and that has really interesting
implications i mean whether it's the
leak of the papers that we've just seen
the last pandora papers in the last 48
hours suddenly casting a spotlight in a
way that would have been unimaginable 30
40 years ago whether it's things like
hashtag metoo where suddenly women who
had been fragmented powerless
isolated managed to use an information
sharing platform to coalesce and
actually topple some people and i
wouldn't pretend for a millisecond that
those that shift in power is complete or
perfect whatsoever but it's striking
compared to the past and back to your
point about capitalism has it been tried
perfectly do we have examples absolutely
not but i go back to that winston
churchill point it's
the worst system to organize an economy
except for the others that have been
tried
right let's roll on we'll keep questions
and answers flowing pretty rapidly if we
could just to get a lot of variety yes
madam hello hi there my question is from
miss tatt and those four factors from
the theory of moral sentiments that you
mentioned
my question is in this competitive
system driven by profit where money is
basically what you're
uh where wealth is basically what you
are valued by isn't it inevitable that
the winners of the system will co-opt
the political system that is supposed to
cre and therefore unequal access is
inevitable
yep i would argue that's one reason why
you need checks and balances okay we're
going to take another question from here
because it's perfectly balanced tonight
impartiality but i just think it's just
a good way of getting a load of
questions in so another gentleman on the
left like capitalism and short-termism
are like identical twins and essentially
you have them hand-in-hand to have
instant gratification to technology and
also instantaneous markets but we live
in a world where you have long-term
problems for climate change
and you need global coordination not
competition how is capitalism going to
be compatible with that
great questions from both great
questions janice um quick replans if he
could
adam smith's idea was that through
the market
conflict of interest turns into
collaboration coordination but he
himself knew the limits of this
for instance when it came to education
he thought that this doesn't work
the problem however is and this is an
answer to both questions
that you know if you look at the theory
of moral sentiments which
jillian did very well to bring up
you know smith quite rightly explains
that the baker the the butcher and the
brewer in order to
provide the common good
for the common good even though that's
not their intention
the intention is to make a living for
themselves
they need to have
a
you know a bed of
shared models and shared values on which
to operate the problem is that with the
second industrial revolution and now
especially with the digital revolution
you have economies of scale in the
economies of scope that destroy
both the moral
bed
on which the baker
the brew and the butcher can operate as
well as their businesses they are taken
over by starbucks or whatever
and then suddenly both the theory of the
modern of moral sentiments and the
wealth of nations goes out of the window
and we have what i think is
can be described quite feasibly and
reasonably as techno federalism
that's why we need anti-monopoly laws
that's why we need regulation that's why
we need government it's not an either or
you know if you're going to play a good
game of soccer
you need to have an umpire you need to
have agreed rules you need to have
someone organize a league
but you still need to have the players
compete
and that's why i'm calling you your
topic
because it is impossible to have those
rules in these governments when you have
two parties both representing the techno
feudal lords
in parliament in every country well i
would argue that actually doing without
the competition doing without the
product motive without doing without the
pricing because pricing i still think is
an amazingly good mechanism for
crystallizing probability and
competition without without all that
that's even more utilized i agree that's
why we need to do away with capitalism
to have proper competition in proper
property markets so you argue that
socialist socialism done properly would
include
better markets and better companies that
is not a vision of socialism i've often
seen well i'm you know i'm not your run
of the military socialist what can i do
[Applause]
we call it socialism 3.0 those of you
who've watched federer nadal
know that where that rally was going
right um let's get a couple more
questions and i've got a couple from our
audience at home sorry to speed us up a
little bit but we'll have to do that
just to get the nice range of voices i'd
love to hear yes sir and then and
any women would like to join the queue
please do because men always do women
not so much right we're up here
oh my goodness hello
is that what they did with you
listen if you have a question i'll come
to you next not that i can actually see
anything but you know it's great to know
you're there so i should take this
gentleman because i said i would a
question for janice you described it's
an unprecedented situation the
monopolies of the digital platforms and
that capitalism can't recover from that
but arguably the context of standard oil
the rockefellers with railways and the
fledgling sort of u.s capitalist states
in the 1890s was much more impactful in
those days and through regulation
capitalism was fixed jillian describes
data transparency and governance and
regulation why can't that fix the
current situation with digital platforms
i have a supporter somewhere in the hall
great
was there a question from upstairs which
might be a little difficult but i
couldn't resist that call from the gods
hi
it's me hello
go ahead i was just wondering um what
you all thought about like emerging um
socialist societies like the zapatistas
in mexico or stuff to that nature
could you just
just that last about merging social
societies was that the question
societies yeah like like do you want an
example like
um like like the zapatistas in mexico
right sample okay hold your thoughts
thank you well done by the way from
getting in touch
and there's another gentleman here thank
you so much so uh i mean all three of us
i need to should come to the all right
sorry sorry
so both speakers today i think i also
agree like we noticed that there is this
um remarkable emergence and
proliferation of these super companies
the corp governments but i was wondering
why i was wondering why janice you think
that
this is a terminal point of capitalism
rather than the some cyclical feature of
the system when uh you know large
companies existed and were eventually
gobbled up by governments the most
notable example being the east india
company and why cooperatives are going
to replace them when cooperatives by
their very nature have no incentives to
reinvest
and expand their operations
great quick points on each
i will combine the standard oil question
with this question about east india
company the east indian government is a
very interesting example because you see
if it was if capitalism was less of that
it would never have succeeded the reason
why capitalism succeeded was because it
went beyond
what the east indian government did
with production not just simply
exploitation expropriation and trade and
arbitrage but the standard oil questions
is fascinating look
rockefeller and standard oil was
extremely powerful and you know theodore
roosevelt amazingly well to break it up
and the anti-trust and legislation is um
you know to be uploaded
can we do the same no i don't think so i
don't think we can do the same with
amazon with facebook and let me tell you
why
standard oil was a monopoly
there was a market
you know they managed to corner the
market every petrol station in almost
every state was owned by them
by user market
right
compare standard oil and contrast it
with amazon
imagine a science fiction horror movie
where you know or scenario where you
step out in bristol and suddenly you
realize as you're walking down the
street
that every building
belongs to the same person
everything that is being bought or sold
is controlled by one person or the
algorithm owned by one person that the
park bench on which you see it is
controlled by the same person
but
moreover not only the air that you
breathe but what you can see
and what you can't see is controlled by
the same person this is worse than
orwell that's amazon
that is not a monopoly
that the only thing i can imagine coming
close to that is the fifth doom you know
downtown abbey
the lord owns the whole thing
only this time it's a technology
and the power that that bestows upon the
people who own it
and the people who own the people who
own the people who own all the other
companies that are fading
within the capital israel is such that i
do not believe it is possible to do that
which roosevelt did with standard oil
try to go back to the questions if you
could julian yeah just anything that
hasn't i just wanted to go back to the
issue about zapatista which was a very
interesting point to make and i should
say by the way that um as part of my
belief in the power of competition i
also believe in
pluralism in different models different
types of companies i should say that i
don't i am to believe that um societies
and economies are best served and you
have a divergence of ownership
structures and ownership models i don't
think that having public equity markets
listed um companies is the only way to
run companies i think you should have
checks and balances
and going back to the issue about
whether there are other ways to organize
societies i say bring on the experiments
and let's see what works so by fiat had
the same uh just trying to take a couple
of thoughts and questions that have come
in by carrier pigeon
from the from those at home and
welcome thank you for staying with us
selma asks is there a version of
capitalism that wouldn't require
constant growth of
profit um i guess you would say no to
that
um i think there's a version of
capitalism where you could certainly
introduce regulations that wouldn't
introduce growth at all costs and
ignoring the externalities and the
footprint of companies
but the
imperative to have growth competition um
you know is a great driver of innovation
okay let's get the lady over here hello
um
can capitalism exist without
exploitation because frankly one of the
arguments against capitalism is how
exploitative it is for people that it
exists
that exists in a way that
rich people are able to stay so so like
really affluent
and
there are people that are that exist
that are just like exceedingly poor so
is there a world that exploitation
cannot happen at all
great question i think better brexit
wrote about 25 plays about it so that's
a really big idea can i jump in there
and say can you i'm not sure you can i
think i'm going to take the other joke
out first
not because i'm in i'm just i'm i'm like
i'd be right down that i think it's a
great question i i just very conscious
we could stay on a little bit we have
one more okay let's do this this
gentleman my questions were julian so i
hope you jump in on to this one um
you spoke about how there is sort of
radical transformation of technology and
we have more information at our
fingertips so we can decide better but
there was little discussion about the
agency that people have so three
quarters of the world or at least 40
percent of the world is living below the
poverty line so they don't really have
the agency of choosing whether or not to
interact with google or whoever uh so in
that situation can capitalism be counted
upon that now i can choose to interact
with a company or not choose to interact
based on where i'm placed so rather
interrelated questions as it turned out
julian first the answer is that i
would argue no you can't rely just on
capitalism alone to fix that definitely
not that's why you need government and
regulation
however having better information is a
good place to start and a good place to
start getting people focused on trying
to campaign for change and focusing on
it
because the key point is this can
capitalism exist without exploitation
not if you believe that any competition
produces winners or losers
and if you think the competition spurs
people to compete harder to fight harder
and to innovate and help growth then
that's inevitable but what you can do is
introduce checks and balances to
actually rein in the egregious levels of
exploitation and competition and prevent
the winners from abusing the losers um
and prevent that being recycled over
generations absolutely
i would also turn around ask janice and
say this
my experience of looking at systems
which claim to be socialist or run on
socialist systems
principles is that they often have
embedded insidious forms of exploitation
of inequality but less acknowledged as
well i've yet to see a truly egalitarian
socialist system
well look
i
where we will agree is that we cannot
have
a society which is free
and worth living
in and fighting for
if it's not based on markets
and competition here we can agree
where we disagree is on is on private
ownership
of things that are necessary in order to
produce other things
capital this is where this agreement is
now jillian may very well say that and
she would be right
that a market
which
operates without private ownership of
means of production has never been tried
before
it's true
what i'm saying is it is time to go for
it because the alternative which is
regulating the beasts
of uh
um
this capitalist system which i call
technophilism by the way um
for me this is it's a question of which
is going back to the
to a previous uh altercation which is
more eutopic
to think that you can regulate this
beast which is running out of control
and is
seriously anti-liberal anti-democratic
it's turning against the basic
principles of liberalism remember
friedrich von hayek the great guru
of the libertarians even of thatcher
once said that you know socialists are
not bad people he said about us
the problem is that in order to enact
socialism they have to do to do things
that contradict their principles i
reverse that and i'm saying that those
who are advocating in favor of
capitalism but they're not you're not
bad people you want good things and
things that we share but in order to do
it you will have to violate your own
liberal principles
let's take two more questions and for
that may be what we have time for in the
hall we have one more up here hello is
that another is that
the voice from yes
all right okay i'll take pity three
they'll shoot me after you know what's
gonna happen don't you
the
lady here and then up there and the
gentleman i'm afraid we'll have to
compress them into one glorious round of
just a minute off you go thank you so my
question is directed to janice so one of
the main points with which you seem to
differ with capitalism was on profits so
you've mentioned as another alternative
for the government making money just
basically printing money which of course
is not a sustainable solution in the
long term so without companies being
profit they're in a competitive
environment what incentive do companies
really have to then fund those
governments right hold that thought
hello hello thank you um so my question
is about power in both the visual utopic
visions that you've presented and
there's something about what you said
that assumes that inequalities will be
eradicated once capitalism capitalism is
either fixed
or
completely taken over by something new
but that doesn't account for what cedric
robinson has written about racial
capitalism and actually racial
inequality and the black lives matter
movement about it which is very
anti-capitalist so in your utopic models
what
very good that you brought that up
actually that would have been a big big
miss if we haven't had it i know sorry
it's going to be extremely squeezed just
the way our time is run but
you might both have a thought on that
and i'll take the gentleman here as well
just to i just wanted to get your views
on
how much
of
the issue with capitalism might be the
over financialization of it because we
have a situation where
global capital markets are now worth
more than cumulative global gdp um and
where does this stop does this break at
some point or
will the qe so you dealt with that a bit
earlier
yep okay all right
please please range range freely but i
would like to hear certainly
i would like to very much answer the
second question because we didn't talk
about as much as we should sure so who's
going to have the last word oh just get
on with him
do you want to have a go so you're going
to
have
i don't me which depends on the pub
closes but go
no no i will go first so
so jillian can have the last word oh i
see well okay okay so very briefly
i hate doing this but i'll do it
i explained this in the book seriously
you know just in case you haven't i'm
not saying that i'm explaining it in a
convincing way but my answer to your
question is there how can you have a
fully functioning market-based system
which is technologically advanced free
liberal
democratic without capitalism it's in
there i'm not going to try to emulate it
but let me say something about power
racism and i will add patriarchy
i don't believe that we have the answers
to these things in my in you know this
is a novel and
in it i try to make it absolutely clear
that i do not believe
that my side of politics even my very
quaint version of socialism even if we
manage to sort out all the problems with
corporations with the power of capital
to exploit to reproduce itself and so on
that we can deal with patriarchy
or racism
discrimination runs very deeply in our
societies
and you know we can reduce the toxicity
which always breeds more racism and more
xenophobia and more sexism
but
i'm pessimistic about human nature we
really need i you know i look into
myself and i find a nazi living in me a
racist living in me a sexist living in
me i constantly have battles with me
with myself and anybody who tells me
that you're not like that you're lying
we are all
like this we all have a dark side and we
all need to fight constantly against it
[Applause]
julian i would say that
one of the messages that anthropology
tries to hammer home
is that by immersing yourself in the
lives of others who seem strange to you
you don't just get empathy for another
point of view
and a vision of how you could do things
differently you also get the ability to
look back at yourself with more clarity
and understand yourself because the fish
can't see water unless they jump out of
their fishbowl
and i think that's what we need to do
today because we assume that the vision
of capitalism that we've seen in the
last 20 or 30 years is the only vision
of capitalism out there that could
possibly exist
and that's simply not true
the profit principle the competition
principle the idea of trade
has been expressed in many different
ways
markets have been expressed in many
different ways too
giannis now appears to be defining
markets as something that you can have
in socialism
great bring it on incorporate it back
into a broader church of capitalism
under that idea but my key point is this
that actually it is possible to
reimagine capitalism it is possible to
fix its flaws it is not a perfect system
but capitalism and markets operate on
the idea that you need to have a
plurality of ideas and competition you
need to have checks and balances
things move in cycles and right now we
need to fix capitalism and i would argue
we actually could with a combination of
digital technology the fact you have
more people empowered the fact we're
being forced to widen our lens beyond
balance sheets to look at things like
the environment and the very fact that
we're having this debate today tonight
where actually janice and i have
probably ended up agreeing on more than
we've been disagreeing on
the last question came in so i'm going
to actually squeegee one in not looking
at the organizers in case they tell me
to get off but
lauren sanchez had a great last question
and this one fortunately you can answer
very few words she said please because
otherwise we'll get kicked out who will
be the biggest players in determining
whether we do fix capitalism if it can
be fixed thank you lawrence great
question
very last thought honestly julian and
then we take another vote it can't be
fixed because it has evolved out of
itself
to no big players because doesn't matter
capitalism is not a problem anymore i
thought you're going to say we have
another problem capitalism in the same
way if i'm right right in the same way
that you know if we were having this
discussion in the in 1800 how can we fix
feudalism the answer is it's not
relevant capitalism is already taking
over let's talk about capitalism
i would say in the 1800s similarly today
i'm saying capitalism is no longer
relevant it's dead everything else is
topical that we're discussing uh about
how we can fix capitalism
democracy by means of you know
regulation and so on
it's a different beast we're facing and
we're all going to be victims of it
it's a highly liberal let's let's get
julian's final final word and then the
vote uh who are the big players in this
fixing capitalist who is going to
address it or fix it well inevitably the
next generation
short and sweet absolutely great let's
retake our vote let's see if anyone's
changed their mind since the beginning
of our energetic debate who thinks
capitalism albeit with tweaks and
reforms and twiddles and regulation and
whatever is still the best economic
system we've got
hmm
i don't know i don't think that's as
many as when we started but i'm an
entirely unfair judge
and who thinks we need a completely new
economic system
well i don't know panel what do you
think uh who's who can give a view on i
think that was fairly
i think we lost do you think it would be
fair who else is looking into the
audience hannah did you have a look it's
very hard to do these are boys games you
should not be playing these boys games
who wonder who lost well you said that
doesn't believe in competition and i do
so
so by default i win
speaking speaking as the patriarchy
i think that uh perhaps some votes went
from that original proposition i'm not
sure where they landed because they seem
to come out and it probably is down to
the brilliance of us because it seemed
to come out about 50 50 at the end so
there you are thank you so much to
janice verofakis to julian for a great
conversation
[Applause]
they will both as promised or threatened
be signing books at the back of the
venue
so if you'd like a copy do stick around
and i'm sure they'll have a word with
you as well they came in from athens and
new york and i came from amwell street
it's been great thank you all so much
where you came from thank you